allez de l'avenir énergétique de la
france passe à la hausse des prix et à
la guerre en ukraine des questions se
posent sur l'approvisionnement du pays
faut-il craindre les restrictions voire
des pénuries cet hiver pour y faire face
le gouvernement a décidé de rouvrir la
centrale à charbon de saint-avold en
moselle on va vous y emmener dans
quelques instants mais d'abord on va
accueillir nos invités il s'installe sur
ce plateau bonjour daniel salmon merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous est sénateur
socialiste d'ille et vilaine et mon jour
anton de réunions merci d'être là
remettant en chef adjoint alternatif
économique et vous êtes auteur de ce
livre qu'on va voir nucléaire stop ou
encore style avant d'entamer ce débat
avec vous le point jury oui quelques
chiffres oriane sur nos os 56 réacteurs
en exploitation 27 sont actuellement à
l'arrêt c'est tout simplement la moitié
de notre parc plusieurs d'entre eux sont
à l'arrêt pour cause de sûreté en
l'occurrence pour des raisons de
corrosion on en a déjà beaucoup parlé
sur public sénat et on va continuer
parce qu'avec la guerre en ukraine et la
baisse des approvisionnements russes
c'est une question qui est devenu très
politique aussi évidemment et on va en
parler pendant ces 20 minutes d'abord
antoine leur avignon on a vu les
chiffres est ce qu'aujourd'hui la france
est un état de fragilité énergétique ou
pas eh bien oui elle est de manière de
manière structurelle
comme comme comme tout pays gros
dépendant extrêmement dépendante des
hydrocarbures
c'est une c'est une fragilité
structurelle
dans le
a fortiori dans le dans le contexte
actuel
fragilité qui dans le cas particulier de
la france se double de son son son
tropisme nucléaire avec un parc par que
vous comme vous l'aviez dit un parent
réacteurs de 2,5 entier de 56 unités qui
fournissent 70% de la production
électrique alors même si c'est la
particularité de ce parc c'est qu'il
commence être être vieux
et donc problème problème de de
corrosion de longueur d'allongement des
durées de ddd temps d'arrêt pour pour
les opérations de maintenance
surprise sur effectivement les preneurs
de corrosion et c'est ce qui fait que on
est dans une situation de grande
fragilité la production électronucléaire
attendu excusez moi en courant de 8 22 c
100 térawattheures
ccc sentir apte au water deux de moins
que ya une dizaine d'années cieux en
état de fragilité aujourd'hui sur le
plan énergétique d'un pays oui on paye
un manque d'anticipation et on paye
c'est vrai notre le fait d'avoir mis un
peu tout et tous les oeufs dans le même
panier avec le nucléaire qui il a montré
également une certaine manière son
intermittence sûr que lorsque l'on à 27
réacteurs à l'arrêt et on peut dire
qu'il ya une grosse intermittence et
donc effectivement il va falloir prendre
ça à bras le corps pour essayer d'avoir
de s'engager dans de la sobriété parce
que moi c'est je le répète nous l'europe
étant assez souvent les écologistes la
première à son énergie qui est là qui
est propre à produire on va dire c'est
celle que l'on ne consomme pas donc
allons-y sur la la sobriété même la
frugalité d'une certaine manière parce
que là on en parlait tout à l'heure
avant de rentrer sur le plateau nous
avons vécu une grosse parenthèse d'une
énergie bon marché facile unis
tarentaise non je parle simplement du
nucléaire je parlerais plutôt du fossile
mais on peut mettre le nucléaire avec
est aujourd'hui bien cette parenthèse il
va falloir arriver à la refermer mais de
quelle manière et justement ça va être
tout l'objet de ce débat en attendant
elle est à saint-avold puisque pour
sécuriser l'approvisionnement du pays le
gouvernement a annoncé qu'il allait
rouvrir la centrale à charbon de
saint-avold en moselle elle avait fermé
ses portes fin mars gaspard flamands
nous y emmène
une fermeture qui pourrait ne durer que
quelques mois après neuf ans à
travailler dans cette centrale en tant
que chef de bloc ce salarié se prépare à
y retourner c'était une vue de la salle
des commandes sur laquelle j'ai
notamment passé beaucoup de beaucoup de
temps voilà c'était un souvenir car la
centrale était vous a jamais redémarrer
au final c'est un document que je
retrouverai probablement sur sur un
ordinateur dissipe thomas est
actuellement en congé de reclassement
quand il entend parler d'une possible
réouverture dans les médias il contacte
son entreprise sans grande annonce de
leur part puisqu'il fallait un cadre
réglementaire notamment le décret le
projet de loi à venir donc sans ce
décret il est fort peu probable que la
direction puisse annoncer des choses
concrètes pour les salariés comme moi on
est en attente c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment ce qu'on attend c'est une
sortie de l'état et ses fameux dec
on est de ce côté là maintenant on est
dans ce que l'on appelle la tranche 600
mégawatts la tranche 6 et c'est
l'installation qui va très certainement
redémarrer dans les mois qui viennent
jean pierre d'âme et le leader syndical
de la centrale il y travaille depuis 49
ans en prenant de la hauteur à 92 mètres
de haut il constate la reprise
d'activité donc devant nous on voit bien
que il ya une un tas de charbon qui
commence à agrandir et il ya au moins de
mars c'était blanc comme
comme on voit donc bonne foi il y avait
il n'y avait plus rien qui avaient plus
à une tonne gaieté sur site donc là on a
l'équivalent de 170 mille tonnes de
charbon ce qui va représenter un peu
près connu
un mois de fonctionnement avant la
fermeture jean-pierre dame faisait
tourner la centrale avec 86 collègues
aujourd'hui il en faudrait 70 pour un
fonctionnement correct problème la
moitié sont depuis partis en retraite et
peu de visibilité pour l'instant sur ce
qui pourrait revenir ce syndicaliste
dénonce le manque d'anticipation de
l'entreprise sur cette réouverture tout
le monde savait que ce risque existait
tout le monde aurait dû nous inciter
gazelles à maintenir mes salariés
préparent et l'outil et est on prêt
vraiment au 1er octobre comme on le
souhaite parce que les conditions
aujourd'hui ne permettent pas de dire
que nous serons prêts le premier temps
pensera peu près mi octobre au 1er
novembre mais tout ça c'est du temps de
perdu des accusation que récuse la
direction elle affirme qu'en l'absence
de consignes claires du gouvernement
il était impossible de maintenir une
unité en marche au mois de mars cette
reprise d'activité est aussi critiquée
pour son impact sur l'environnement pour
le maire de la commune de saint-avold il
faut anticiper la reconversion du
territoire on est à temps à un
territoire d'énergie
et demain en restaurant un territoire
d'énergie mais d'énergie verte je veux
par la dir le projet hydrogène en un
gros projet hydrogène et la reconversion
de nos territoires c'est s'est passé
d'une énergie entre guillemets
polluantes à une énergie plus verte si à
l'échelle nationale la production
d'électricité par charbon représente
ramondenc % ici en lorraine la centrale
permet d'aliments et sept cent mille
foyers soit un tiers de la région grand
est
regardant ce reportage qu'est ce que
vous pensez vous du fait que le
gouvernement va irait au reer cette
centrale à charbon de saint-avold
c'est un constat d'échec on va dire
revenir sur du charbon alors qu'on sait
pertinemment qu'il faut sortir de cette
ce mode de production d'électricité qui
est le plus polluant de tous s'est
montré que l'on n'a pas pris les choses
en main dans les années précédentes même
si je le je le conçois il y a des
éléments aujourd'hui qui sont arrivés
avec la guerre en ukraine qui viennent
bousculer les bousculer le jeu mais bien
mettez qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement
n'avait pas le choix dans le contexte
actuel non je pense qu'il reste il y a
toujours des choix dans la vie il faut
il faut faire les bons et je pense que
quand je vous parlais de sobriété on
sait qu'aujourd'hui rien que l'éveil
l'éveil dans les maisons aujourd'hui
c'est l'équivalent pratiquement d'un
réacteur nucléaire donc je pense que en
allant en se préparant les français à
une sobriété appuyé à l'hiver prochain
on peut se passer de ces de ce genre de
centrales qui sont très émettrices alors
c'est une centrale de 500 mégawatts doit
vous voyez il ya je suis breton hand en
baie de saint brieuc on a un parc éolien
offshore qui doit faire à peu près 500
mégawatts et bien voilà ça piétine ça
fait très longtemps qu'il devrait être
lancé et bien voilà c'est son cd vous
dire il va pas le jour il ya des
contestations dont comment fait
aujourd'hui pour assurer la sécurité en
tout cas l'approvisionnement énergétique
de la france cet hiver
à banaliser non mais je veux faire
réagir d'abord avant de vous poser cette
question daniel salmon reportage
convient de voir antoine de réunion est
ce que la ferme loi réouverture pardon
de cette centrale à charbon pour vous
elle était nécessaire et est-ce qu'elle
a été suffisamment bien préparé quand on
entend les gens sur place je pense qu'il
est difficile de préparer ce genre de
choses la la la la la human la guerre en
ukraine et était pas par définition
imprévisible donc on est dans une
situation d'urgence il faut passer il
faut passer l'hiver
personnellement je suis pas
je certes des dna si on avait mieux
anticiper la nôtre notre transition
notre transition bas carbone on aurait
peut-être pu éviter cette cette
réouverture en en urgence
personnellement ça me choque pas
excessivement sait il s'agit sans doute
d'une mesure d'une mesure d'urgence et
si c'est destiné à passer l'hiver et
pour vous ça va être une mesure
d'urgence ou c'est du provisoire qui
pourrait durer je pense que c'est je
pense que c'est du provisoire je le
fasse c'est comme ça que je le jeu ne
comprendra pas besoin de
l'objectif c'est qu'on sait qu'on sorte
très rapidement eu du charbon et des
fossiles là les choses les choses sont
claires le problème c'est qu'on a on a
une une orientation de long terme qui
est qui est assez claire qui est la
sortie au cirque elle à la sortie de des
fossiles au dc d'ici 2050 pour tous les
pays européens une baisse de moitié
d'ici 2030 dans huit ans mais vous avez
vu le rapport du haut conseil pour le
climat a publié hier
qui nous dicte le rythme des années deux
fois trop trop faible par rapport à ce
qu'il faudrait faire donc si en même
temps que l'annoncent delà de la delà du
prolongement de quelques de quelques
mois
de saint-avold on me dit oui on met le
paquet sur sûre et sur les économies
d'énergie sur la sobriété sur sur la
relance des des sources des sources bas
carbone j'achète le problème c'est qu'on
n'a pas ça on a on est dans un flou
total sur sur sur ce qu'il faut faire
aujourd'hui pour pour engager cette 7,7
cette transition bas carbone on piétine
et donc c'est ce qui rend cette session
ce débat sur la centrale à charbon c'est
assez inaudibles c'est que on pourrait
l'accepter comme sérieuses comme
solution d'urgence si à côté il y avait
qu il y avait un plan un plan clair
c'est pas aussi liées à la volonté des
écologistes d'abaisser la part du
nucléaire dans le mix est ce que si on
avait plus travaillé sur le nucléaire on
ne serait pas obligé aujourd'hui de
rouvrir cette centrale à charbon
c'est un c'est un vrai sujet c'est clair
que on a un parc nucléaire qui est très
dix ans le nucléaire d'une manière
chronique est une énergie sale et qui en
vieillissant et de plus en plus
dangereuse effectivement on revient
souvent sur fessenheim et pourquoi est
ce qu'on à fermer fessenheim parce que
fessenheim et sur une faille parce que
fessenheim n'est pas du tout aux normes
post fukushima
il aurait fallu des investissements
colossaux et on voit bien aujourd'hui
que le centrale nucléaire on a parlé de
la corrosion aujourd'hui on a parlé des
problématiques de maintenance avec le co
vide n'est pas en état de fournir de
l'énergie effectivement donc le
nucléaire doit être réinterrogé dans sa
globalité effectivement nous sommes pour
une sortie pour une sortie du nucléaire
dans les une ou deux décennies qui
viennent parce que comme on n'a pas
anticipé on est face au mur
donc on a déposé une loi d'ailleurs sur
la sûreté nucléaire pour faire en sorte
qu' on puisse faire continuer ses
centrales au moins pendant une décennie
sans qu'on aille vers la catastrophe
donc on en est là aujourd'hui mais sur
ce plateau
je suis plus il ya une quinzaine de
jours j'étais venu sur la rénovation
thermique savez que quand vous rénovez
un million de passoires thermiques vous
économisez la production de deux à trois
réacteurs
sujet justement je sais je sais je sais
plus si c'était avec vous que j'ai eu
cet échange non mais on va sortir
650000 rénovation non 650000 dépôts de
dossiers ma prime raynaud 658 ce sont
des petits gestes qui n'ont pas mené des
rénovations globales on devrait à 600 à
700 milles rénovation globale qui sont
des vrais rénovation et là on a fait des
petits gestes qui en face et de
l'applicatif pour reparler justement de
cette stratégie sur le nucléaire s'il va
regarder pour nous avait fait le bilan
du quinquennat d' emmanuel macron sur
cette question du nucléaire un
quinquennat marqué par quelques
revirements des revirements et un coming
out à l'occasion de l'élection
présidentielle mais avant d'en parler on
va peut-être faire un petit retour en
arrière retour en 2010 est juste avant
son élection emmanuel macron disait
vouloir baisser la part du nucléaire
dans le mix électrique français il
s'inscrivait alors dans les pas de
françois hollande qui promettait la
réduction du nucléaire de 75 à 50% de
notre mix énergétique d'ici à 2025 on
écoute le candidat emmanuel macron
un problème de dépendance parce que ça
n'est pas bon d'avoir 75 % de notre
énergie électrique qui dépendent
nucléaire maintenant est ce que le 50%
en 2025 est atteignable je ne sais pas
vous le dire aujourd'hui mais je veux me
mettre dans cette trajectoire voilà et
après son élection emmanuel macron
arrive réaffirmé son engagement pas de
sortie du nucléaire mais une réduction
de sa part mais attention la réduction
de 75 à 50% n'est plus un objectif pour
2025 qui devient un objectif pour 2035
des annonces concrètes sont fait
quelques mois plus tard fin 2010 8
emmanuel mâcon prométhée l'arrêt de 14
réacteurs d'ici à 2035 un mouvement qui
commence effectivement à l'été 2020 avec
l'arrêt définitif des deux réacteurs de
fessenheim c'était une promesse de
françois hollande à l'origine promesses
tenues promesses réalisé par emmanuel
macron donc en 2000 regardez en 2020
justement le discours du chef de l'état
va compenser à 100 flèche oui alors par
petites touches un progressivement sans
vraiment le dire dans une interview à
brut en décembre 2020 emmanuel macron
déclare à la chose suivante le nucléaire
m'importe le nucléaire c'est de l'emploi
et c'est de l'énergie je ne suis pas
anti nucléaire gelé toujours dit avec
beaucoup de force ce revirement des
manuels macron s'accentue l'année
suivante en novembre 2000 21 il annonce
la construction de nouveaux réacteurs et
puis et puis en février 2022 à belfort
il dévoile le plan france 2030 écoutez
je souhaite que si je perds 2 soit
construit et que nous lancions les
études sur la construction de huit le
pr2 additionnel
nous avons seront ainsi par paliers
voilà macron un prométhée est bien de
fermer des centrales nucléaires macron 2
promet de rouvrir des centrales
nucléaires existe-t-il ou pas une
doctrine maquereau en la matière
joker
pour vous
c'est une doctrine qui évolue comme
beaucoup des politiques du gouvernement
et je pense que aujourd'hui le lobby du
nucléaire a fait son travail et on voit
ce glissement qui montre bien une
absence de grogne vertébrale et quand on
se lance dans une transition écologique
il faut une colonne vertébrale il faut
savoir où on va il faut anticiper est ce
que dans kontakt à quel emmanuel macron
avait d'autre choix que de relancer la
construction de centrales nucléaires
entendre avignon on va bien sûr qu'on a
on a on a le choix c'est la conclusion
que l'on peut faire du rapport
r telus est donc le réseau de transport
d'électricité
il y avait du cran scénario alors
s'étaient lancés alors d'abord je petite
parenthèse je partage pas l'analyse
selon laquelle
le président de la république ait voulu
à changer de doctrine sur le nucléaire
il a toujours été pro nucléaire est
favorable
un
programme de relance de nouveaux
réacteurs
oui mais c'est le c'était des sites et
des réacteurs qui étaient c'était un ct
1 passe et 1 passe et c'était 1 c'était
un passé on était sur une promesse
antérieure
laquelle est la question s'est pas
d'abord 50% nucléaire ou pas la question
c'est de savoir si on
construit de nouveaux réacteurs ou pas
pour nos besoins pour de demain ou si on
s'en passe et on l'est on laisse
s'éteindre progressivement le parc de
même que le débat n'est pas de savoir
2025 ou 2030 5 2025 c'était de toute
évidence complètement irréaliste par
rapport à l'état développement de la
filière des défilés ap renouvelables
donc été logique de reporter sa pas fait
plaisir aux écologique mais aux
écologistes on pouvait pas faire
autrement donc la vraie question c'est
est ce qu'on tombe est ce que il faut
construire ou pas de deux nouveaux
réacteurs au début de son mandat le
président a dit on c'était dans la
foulée de la deûle à de la gadoue après
le début de crise des gilets jaunes ou
dans souvenez il dit on va demander on
va commander une étude étudiants les
différents scénarios donc là on était
vraiment je pense à ce moment là dans
une dans une dans une volonté de mettre
tous les scénarios chaussures sur la
table ces scénarios c'est cette étude a
été a été produite dont coproduite par
l'aïe agence internationale de l'énergie
aie rte pour dire d'une part donc
1ce techniquement c'est possible on peut
faire un système électrique sans sans
nucléaire on peut sortir du nucléaire on
y arrive d'un point de vue t21 point une
technique iat padilla pas d'obstacle
dirimant
et de le deuxième volet de l'étude qui
sort qui sort en novembre en novembre
2000 21 c sur la question des coûts sur
les aspects socio-économiques
est ce que un scénario de sortie du
nucléaire
ou enfin un scénario de relance du
nucléaire coûte plus cher ou un cher
qu'un scénario de sortie et la
conclusion de de rte montre qu'il ya des
écarts de coûts mais qui sont pas
exorbitants et surtout si on regarde les
différences et les deux les différents
scénarios et qu'on se rapproche des
scénario médian et si on enlève les
questions de
deux coups de si on regarde on enlève un
certain nombre d'hypothèses sur les
coûts de financement on peut dire on
s'aperçoit que des des coûts de sortie
ou de coût d'entrée enfin le coût de
sortie du nucléaire ou coup de relance
sont finalement les jets qui veut dire
en clair antoine alain chauveau on a le
choix
ça veut dire qu emmanuel macron n'était
pas obligé de relancer la filière
nucléaire pour vous absolument pas
daniel salmon imagine que vous êtes
d'accord ben complètement
le
jeu reprend les mêmes mots on est devant
un choix de société est-ce que l'on
repart sur du nucléaire du nouveau
nucléaire avec toutes les problématiques
qui vont avec aujourd'hui vous le savez
est ce qu on est en capacité de dire ce
qui va se passer dans cinq ans dans dix
ans dans 15 ans le nucléaire implique
d'avoir une société technologique sur
des siècles voire des millénaires or on
est incapable de promettre cela on voit
bien que il ya cinq ans ne savait pas
qu'il y aurait une pandémie on ne savait
pas qui aurait la guerre en ukraine on
va aller vers d'un monde de plus en plus
instable on le voit tous les jours et le
nucléaire n'est pas compatible avec la
stabilité très clairement c'est une
énergie engageante sur le temps long et
le temps long nous ne maîtrisons pas
donc effectivement il faut c'est notre
avis à louis écologistes il faut surtout
éviter sans dégager sinon une nouvelle
filière du nouveau nucléaire un dernier
mot puisque vous
j'étais tout à l'heure dans le journal
du dimanche cette tribune des trois gros
fournisseur d'énergie dans le pays qui
alertent justement sur les conséquences
sur la fracture sociale de cette montée
des prix de l'énergie et qui appelle les
français à réduire leur consommation est
ce que pour vous cette réduction de la
consommation elle pourra se faire de
manière volontaire j'allais dire où est
ce qu'il faudra imposer des restrictions
aux entreprises et aux particuliers
la difficulté c'est qu'il faut une
acceptabilité et donc il s'agit pas que
ce soient les plus démunis qui paye le
plus lourd tribut donc effectivement il
va falloir voir comment on peut
harmoniser faire en sorte qu
effectivement il ya des il ya des
entreprises électro intensives il va
falloir et bien prévoir effectivement de
les déconnecter par moments et puis il
va falloir faire en sorte que
énormément de gaspillage qui sont sans
doute qu'ils sont même pas sans doute
qu'ils sont certainement fait par les
classes les plus aisées soit la renier
merci beaucoup merci messieurs pour ce
débat sur sur l'avenir énergétique de la
france
[Musique]